well in russia the kremlin has been
tightening its grip on social media
platforms
this month the country's media watchdog
threatened to block sites like twitter
if they failed to remove banned content
and now the video sharing platform
tick-tock is on the kremlin's radar as
well
during opposition protests in support of
alexei navalny the site was flooded with
political content
and as dw correspondent emily sherwin
reports
that means scrutiny for the site's 20
million russian users
time could be ticking for these tick
tock bloggers
the unlikely new enemy for the kremlin
the social network is mostly about
entertainment
with videos of pranks and dance routines
but this month at a meeting with the
police russian president vladimir putin
made it clear he wants the authorities
to be watching anyway
unfortunately we all know what the
internet is and how it is used to
promote unacceptable content
it's critical for you to unite with
other government agencies
in order to monitor the web and be more
proactive in identifying people who are
dragging minors into committing illegal
actions
the fact that minors are being dragged
into illegal unauthorized
street protests as well is of course a
violation of the law
[Music]
tick tiktok in particular has been on
the authorities radar since the return
of opposition politician alexey navalny
to russia
his arrest in january caused a wave of
opposition protests across the country
and a sudden explosion of politics on
tick-tock
teenagers filmed themselves at schools
replacing portraits of putin
with portraits of navain
another tick-tock trend was videos of
teens getting ready to protest and
telling their parents
they might get arrested russia's media
watchdog responded by calling on
tick-tock to block videos
calling for unauthorized protests and
last week threatened to block social
networks completely if they don't comply
with russian laws
[Music]
but these moscow tick talkers want to
keep dancing to their own tune
without thinking about politics every
week the bloggers meet at this so-called
tick-tock house with their producers
to consult about their accounts and
collaborate with each other
to stay on trend tick-tockers like
virani kareznikova filmed two to three
videos a day
the 17-year-old thinks the videos about
politics were just a short-lived trend
there's too much politics on tick tock i
went on there during the protests and
there was none of the usual content in
my feed
it was all about politics navini and
putin who's for whom
it freaked me out i stayed off tick tock
for a few days
fitness blogger diana sonina also says
she doesn't want tick tock to become a
political platform
tick tock is a social media platform for
self-expression
there's so much negative stuff around us
already on state television and so on
if that stuff is on tick-tock as well
then we'll just drown in all these
problems
something has to stay neutral
but being neutral may soon no longer be
possible
according to maxine petrinchuk he's one
of the owners of the pr
agency promoting these bloggers
or against him they're just doing their
thing but when they're told they're
freaks when they're stigmatized
these bloggers start feeling they're
outsiders in this country
and that's what makes them feel angry at
the government
for now these tick-tockers are steering
clear of politics
but even they know that the kremlin will
be watching closely
if they ever get out of step